well I'm
Gil Strang and I'm very happy if you
know the linear algebra videos on
OpenCourseWare or on YouTube that's for
the math course 1806 and I've even
happier if you like them and here today
to update them for several reasons
well lots happened a lot has happened in
linear algebra in these years
fortunately the whole subject has just
become more and more essential more and
more important more more beautiful and
so I wanted to say something about the
those later steps and also when I teach
it now I have a new starting point and
I'll show you that so I'll go a little
slowly on that starting point this the
slides tell you the whole course and
that's like crazy to have a full course
within the short video but especially
the first part is new and and I'm even
writing a textbook called
linear algebra for everyone that will
start this way I hope that the new start
brings in sort of real linear algebra
ideas write it right away and let me
show you where those are so this is an
outline of the whole video and the first
line which I think about in my mind as a
matrix a is the product of a C matrix a
column matrix and a row matrix R and
you'll see what those are so that's the
new idea that when that will come first
then these are five famous essential
shorthand descriptions of the key
chapters of linear algebra the key
chapter so they represent for example Lu
is those letters are famous and and
computer commands would be
actually those letters lu4 elimination
for solving equations the first job of
the linear algebra and then QR so Q is a
very interesting important type of
matrix that's standing for an orthogonal
matrix there's the word orthogonal or
perpendicular so those are the best
matrices to compute with and that QR is
gets us there and s is for a symmetric
matrix and it will involve oh well I
should say the first half ending with
there with QR is about solving equations
the second half the these three are
about eigenvalues and eigenvectors and
singular values a different way to
approach the whole subject and a very
very important way among my goals is to
help courses around the world get
singular values included because you
really don't want to miss them there the
that's a high point of of the theory and
it's expressed like all the others as a
as a breaking a matrix into two or three
pieces two or three parts so that's my
plan for this video and I hope it's
helpful again it's a whole course in a
short time and please go to the real
1806 videos for the details thanks